welcome to top five i'm heather ruse and
i'm Ayano aid this week we're tackling
possibly one of the most popular and
respected trilogies in modern film
history Peter Jackson's Lord of the
Rings trilogy has left a lasting impact
and legacy on our culture released in
2001 the Lord of the Rings the
Fellowship of the Ring started the
trilogy off the two towers was released
in 2002 and returned to the king in 2003
the movies were received very well by
both critics and audiences in fact it is
still one of the highest grossing film
series of all time grossing an
astounding 2.9 billion dollars the
series has also won a great deal of
awards the trilogy as a whole has earned
30 Academy Award nominations winning 17
of those the most awarded film in the
series was The Return of the King which
won all 11 Awards it was nominated for
including Best Picture the music was
also a piece of what made this trilogy
so special Howard Shore composed the
score that was able to transport us to
middle-earth each location has its own
sound that immediately makes you know
where you are and what to feel about it
emotional moments are heightened thanks
to the melodies that really elevate the
tale perfectly I couldn't imagine what
these films would be without the music
just in case you don't know the basic
storyline of the trilogy follows Frodo a
hobbit who is unknowingly gifted the one
true Ring of Power a weapon that could
destroy all of middle-earth if it falls
back into the hands of its creator sour
on Frodo sets out on a journey to
destroy the ring and the fires of Mount
Doom where it was forged he is
accompanied by a group of travelers of
different races that become known as the
Fellowship of the Ring these are the top
5 best Lord of the Rings trilogy moments
number 5
when we first meet the ents they appear
to not wish to engage themselves in a
battle that they don't believe is theirs
to fight they are truly neutral merry
and pippin spent some time with their
leader Treebeard Pippin convinces him to
go to the edge of the forest near
Isengard once there he sees the
destruction caused by Saruman who has
been using the natural resources to
build an army Treebeard is enraged he
calls the ents to battle as we see the
real damage that these ancient spirits
are capable of they start hurling
boulders at the orcs some orcs are even
crushed beneath the mighty trees finally
Treebeard tells the ents to rip apart
the damn water violently rushes through
the compound destroying everything in
its path besides the ents who use their
powerful root legs to stand their ground
perhaps one of my favorite parts of this
is seramins panic he can only watch with
dismay as the ents attack knowing that
he's defeated I also really like some of
the details like this end that was on
fire that puts himself out in the
floodwater this is a scene truly worth
cheering number four he started his
existence as Smithville a hobbit but
once he killed his cousin deagle to get
the ring his fate was sealed Smeagol was
immediately under the influence of the
ring and recoiled to the mountains with
it in his possession for hundreds of
years
Smeagol decayed into his form as Gollum
surviving on raw fish and his obsession
with his precious when the ring was
taken from him he eventually tracked it
back to Frodo and attempted to get it
back when Frodo shows in pity Gollum
does his best to earn his mercy but
golems not so innervoice puts up a fight
his split personality has an argument
that's captivating to watch golems
designs somehow makes him simultaneously
revolting and adorable his big eyes are
filled with sadness and hate the special
effects have also aged surprisingly well
allowing this scene to keep its impact
during his pathetic argument with
himself Andy Serkis does both emotion
sure and voice of Smeagol circus is able
to make the vocal distinction between
the two and the audience is able to
empathize the Smeagol while dismissing
Colin as lost to the greed and evil of
the Ring
circuses performance is a standout here
and will always pull my heartstrings
number three
[Music]
perhaps my favorite of all Sean Bean
on-screen deaths and he's got quite the
repertoire
poor guy from the moment that the
audience first meets Boromir we are
meant to be skeptical and untrusting of
him yet we also feel strangely connected
to him as he seems the most human of all
the characters he is flawed greedy and
stubborn he wants the ring to be taken
to Gondor to be used as a weapon again a
very human thing to think and do all of
this culminates in him attacking Frodo
to steal the ring the Fellowship is then
ambushed in the forest by the Oda Kai
Boromir sounds his horn to bring all of
the army to him he cuts down soldier
after soldier until their captain starts
firing arrows at him
Boromir takes the arrows and continues
fighting he struggles on despite being
hit finally he falls to his knees and
defeats
Aragorn finds him and they have a
beautiful exchange
[Music]
captain
but what I really love about this moment
is how much it truly redeems the
character of Boromir he was able to die
a noble death another sacrifice to the
corruption yet ultimate destruction of
the Ring number two
I have nomads the witch-king of Angmar
was a captain Wraith who served Sauron
and thought to be unstoppable
but the prophecy of Glorfindel said the
witch-king would fall eventually just
not at the hands of man during the
battle of the pelennor fields a wind
watches her father crushed like a twig
shibi heads the winged creature
responsible and faces the witch-king
directly she narrowly holds her own when
he utters no man could defeat him merry
surprises the witch-king by stabbing him
in the leg once wounded and sufficiently
distracted a win' informs him she isn't
a man and stabs him where his face used
to be defeating him and fulfilling the
prophecy some fans find this as a bit of
a cop-out that he wasn't technically
killed by a man since he was defeated by
a woman and a hobbit for them I offer a
similar fate in Shakespeare's Scottish
play Macbeth has given a prophecy that
he will come to power and that none of
woman born shall harm Macbeth when he is
eventually usurped as king by Macduff we
learn it's because macduff was from his
mother's womb untimely ripped
so basically we're splitting hairs over
a c-section but I argue therein lies the
power of belief the witch-king
second-in-command to Sauron had seen
great power and become overconfident in
his abilities going into battle against
some humans knowing none are capable of
harming him let alone killing him
I mean I would get a little careless too
ultimately under estimating his
opponents was his undoing
and aon and Mary were able to use that
against the witch-king to cause his
downfall and the number one best Lord of
the Rings trilogy moment
surrounded by orcs barely started on
their journey together the fellowship is
outnumbered and things are looking bleak
when a fiery light appears it is a
blessing and a curse
gerunds Bane chases away the legion of
Orcs which would be of some comfort
except the fellowship then has to face a
giant Balrog themselves they attempt to
evade it but inevitably Gandalf must
make the decision to split the bridge of
Casas Doom and say his epic line in that
moment the Balrog will not go down
without a fight
literally wrapping its whip around
Gandalf ankle and pulling him down as
well Gandalf the grace final words to
the Fellowship's are fly you fools the
line delivery is powerful and the loss
of a beloved character is heartbreaking
we've learned to love and trust Gandalf
in such a short period of time he's the
reason anyone has made it to this point
in the story it's necessary for the
ultimate rebirth is the powerful gandalf
the white but in this instant
no one knows they'll ever see him again
and Gandalf made the ultimate sacrifice
for the greater good
allowing Frodo to continue and destroy
the ring we want to hear what you guys
think what is your favorite Lord of the
Rings trilogy moment what do you want us
to cover next on the show leave a
comment and let us know if you want to
keep in touch you can find me on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and you
can find me on Twitter Instagram or
twitch
rice stream on Wednesday nights we'll
catch you back here next week on a brand
new episode of top 5 where we take a
look at the worst Lord of the Rings
trilogy moments
[Music]
[Applause]
you